very few people in this country know
much about our imperial history and so
so when zealous uh noisy aggressive folk
tell them that it was a Litany of racism
and oppression
they they don't know enough to
contradict them and also what they do
know is it's it doesn't look good uh if
you contradict what appears to be the
progressive view because because then
you too will get get labeled as being
racist or uh Colonial apologists or
whatever so there's nothing there was
nothing exceptional about the British
involvement in slavery uh what was
exceptional and extraordinary was that
toward the end of the 18th century the
idea that
owning other human beings as property
began to be questioned on principle
Britain was among the first states in
the history of the world to abolish the
slave trade and then to abolish slavery
and it then led the world in suppressing
both of those as I said from Brazil
across Africa to Malaysia that was
extraordinary no other state had done
that before
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a terrific returning guest today
is an ethicist at the University of
Oxford and of course the author of his
latest book colonialism and moral
Reckoning Nigel bigger welcome back to
trigonometry I'm pleased to be back
thank you so much and this time you are
on our set on our turf our last time we
came to you I'm really impressed um no
thank you very much for coming back it's
a real pleasure to have you on uh your
book is out it's caused quite a stir
he's done very well Sunday Times
bestseller several weeks in a row etc
etc
um without any further Ado uh what is
your book about and what was the case
that you wanted to make
so the book is a response
um to a fashionable view namely that
um European colonialism and in
particular British colonialism was a
listening of of racism and economic
exploitation and unwarranted violence so
it was simply evil and uh at the extreme
you'll find people trying to to
approximate uh British Imperial endeavor
with Nazism so
um accusing British Columbia lists of of
um genocide and and such like
uh so the book is response to that
and it argues that yes like like any
long-standing state be it national or
imperial the British Empire contained
evils and goods it it contained for
example 150 years worth of of Engagement
and slave trading and in slavery but
also subsequent to that it was among the
first
states in the history of the world to
abolish the trade and the institution
and then Britain led the world in
suppressing it from Brazil across Africa
to Malaysia so
like like Most states and there's no way
of of kind of
um balancing up the goods and evils and
saying well so many years of
anti-slavery compensates for so many
years of slavery that doesn't make sense
at all
but what I go on to say is well uh no
you you can't identify
um the British Empire with Nazism in any
respect it wasn't essentially uh racist
or exploitative and then you add to that
the fact that there were
persistent uh humanitarian and liberal
threads to Imperial policy anti-slavery
uh and then from from about the 1860s
onwards the the Empire learned from the
fact that it lost the American colonies
in the 1780s and was committed to making
Canada Australia South Africa New
Zealand
independent and they were virtually
Independent by 1930 and India was put in
the same track at the end of the first
World War
um and then the final thing at the point
I make is that the fact that the empire
was committed to fighting the massively
murderous and essentially racist regime
in in Nazi Germany
um and and from May 1940 to June 1941 it
was the only
um military opposition to Nazism with
the exception of Greece that fact tells
you something about the the fundamental
values of the of the of the Empire
notwithstanding all sorts of injustices
and and evils and uh elements of racism
within the Empire and Nigel I know we
touched on this last time before we we
talk about the British Empire
specifically I I've I've been reading a
lot of uh in in the context of the
conflict in Ukraine and I was I've been
reading a Russian uh guy called
Alexander Dugan oh yes I don't know if
you're familiar with him I am uh but
um one of the things he's part of this
movement in Rush of these so-called new
eurasians uh and his he is funny reading
him because his book was written not
that long ago I think in 2000 and he
goes Russians and Imperial people we
must be expanding in order to survive
and to exist
can you talk to us because I think part
of the reason we have this
one-dimensional conversation about this
issue is we seem to have forgotten that
other countries had Empires too yeah can
you talk to us about empires in general
why what are they why do they why do
they exist who creates them what is what
is the rationale for building uh a a
country that essentially not a
nation-state but it's a combination of
different ethnicities and different
relationships to each other tell us
about that yeah good point so um you're
quite right the focus certainly in in
America and in this country is on
European Empires and white Empires the
British Empire in particular
whereas uh Empire has been a
um an historical phenomenon since the um
4000 BC in in uh um Mesopotamia uh um
Arabs did it Africans did it the Chinese
still do it the Comanche did it in in
the southwest of the US and of what's
now the US in the 1800s uh so there's a
strange focus on European Empires which
we could talk about
um what is empire about I mean often
it's it's about security so take
Anglo-Saxon England
uh in the
um I don't know the
um 700s 800s 900s uh A.D in England you
have lots of little kingdoms the borders
are insecure
um the the subject rage from outside uh
the island
and so um in order to to secure their
borders they have to make sure that the
people around them are under their
control and sometimes that would involve
expanding so you you impose your
government on them and so in a sense
many nation states many Old Nation
States
um ex were are the creations of of
series of expansions
um
um and So eventually you end up with
with by about 1000 England is a
virtually a single nation-state but then
in in the
uh 14th century
um you get English kings conquering
Wales and then Ireland so often security
is is a main motive
but then in the case of the the British
Empire
uh trade a major motive so that's that's
the main reason the first reason why the
British ended up in uh Africa and
um in India
and then you've also got ironically
you've got anti-imperial and Endeavor so
one reason the uh English first pitched
up on the coast of North America was to
set up um
um posts or ports from which English
readers could could raid Spanish
shipping at a time when Imperial Spain
Catholic Spain was threatening little
Protestant England so the the motives
for for Empire are are various
um and you mentioned the the Russian the
current Russian example so I guess some
some uh proponents of Empire think that
um
um a certain piece of territory
belongs to them uh by by right or by
nature or something so some Russians
think the Ukraine is a an eternal part
of
Russia regardless of what ukrainians
think and and they feel they own it uh
but but um it's hard to generalized
because that wouldn't be true of every
Empire I mean through the Russian
Empires as a whole
um but there are a variety of motives
Nigel do you ever find it frustrating
the way that we talk about history
nowadays because it seems to me that we
have people arguing about history who
don't really understand history have
never been taught it properly
yes I feel uh frustrated sometimes
by the level of ignorance I'm quite sure
that
the reason why
um the decolonizing movement has taken
roots in so many of our institutions
um particularly since the black lives
matter movement across the Atlantic in
2021 I think 2020 2020 even earlier than
that
um the reason it got traction was
very few people in this country know
much about
uh um are imperial history and so so
when zealous uh noisy aggressive folk
tell them that it was a Litany of racism
and oppression
they they don't know enough to
contradict them and also what they do
know is it's it doesn't look good uh if
you if you um if you um
contradicts what appears to be the
progressive view because because then
you too will get get labeled as being
racist or a colonial apologist or
whatever
so that's that's part of the ignorance
is has been a problem and one thing even
if if a reader doesn't agree with the
argument in my book I I hope that at
least the book will lay out
uh the full story the whole story of the
British instance of of Empire and show
people that it it did contain good bits
as well as bad and it was really quite
complicated and nuanced
so there's that the other thing is odd
is
um and I'm not quite sure how to
articulate this but uh an attitude to
the past is if it ought to be the same
as us
I get really annoyed with with
um
uh television programs or films that
assimilate the past to us so there was a
there was a
film about Emily Bronte made recently
was it was called Emily
uh where the the the story is that
um so Emily Bronte in the ninth Century
wrote this book at Wuthering Heights
which is is full of of of
um romance and sexual passion
and the um the filmmaker decided that
um Emily couldn't possibly have written
this and that she herself had had a
serious uh um uh fling and she herself a
personal experience of of some sexual
Affair
um so so the the film tells the story of
it Emily
along those lines the problem is there
is no historical evidence at all to
suggest that's true uh Emily
um conjured the story out of her own
imagination
um but the 21st century filmmaker just
just can't cope with that so it has to
have to make Emma like 21st century
person but but the thing is that what I
find interesting about the past is its
difference and when you come up against
you know the fact that Emily never
married never apparently had sex as far
as we know and yet she was able to
imagine the story that's interesting
um and what's interesting is it it it
challenges our assumptions which makes
it interesting and core should cause us
to think about the the assumptions and
the things we take for granted but
um so it's so much safer to assimilate
the past to the present because then you
don't have to think about it it's it's a
very interesting point you made it's
almost that we can't believe that Mary
Shelley wrote Frankenstein when she was
18 years old
I know she had some kind of experience
of monsters but anyway
let's let's tackle some of the really
difficult bits of of the Empire because
the one thing that people will say is
the British traded enslaves they had
slaves for many many years that's how
they generated huge amounts of wealth
this is obviously awful Nigel how can
you possibly defend it okay so let me
make it clear I do not approve of
slavery
uh let's let's take that for granted
um
um but
we have to and this is related to the to
the very last point we have to take on
board the fact
that slavery and trading slaves
was a universal Institution
almost from the dawn of time
um so long before Europeans got into it
and the Portuguese were the first in the
1440s
um in terms of of trading in Africans
although there was slavery I mean
Bristol was a slave market in the in the
medieval period Irish slaves being
traded to to Norsemen who then took them
down the Volga to the Black Sea so
there's lots of slave trading around
Europe but also uh Africans were
involved in in trading other Africans as
slaves to the Romans and then and then
to the Muslim Arabs
um the Comanche
the Indian the amerindian people who uh
dwelt in the
Southwest of what's now the United
States
um according to one eminent historian uh
ran a vast slave economy in the 1700s
and then the um um in the 1700s in
Jamaica when when slaves escaped from
the plantations and went into the
forested interior the mountains interior
of Jamaica they're called maroons
they often held slaves of their own and
I was in I was in
Raleigh North Carolina in January
visiting my my wife's family
there and I went to the Museum of the
history of North Carolina
which told me that
um on the eve of the American Civil War
in 1860
there were 30 000 freed slaves in the
state of North Carolina some of whom
owned slaves of their own and my point
is
um we have to
accept the fact that for many people
even former slaves only enslaves was
acceptable or normal
and and even if you um you might well uh
um if you were in the 18th century 19th
Century Century you might well object to
cruel and inhuman forms of slavery
and yet still think that slavery was a
kind of a fact of life
so we just have to accept that and get
our heads around it it doesn't
necessarily mean that everyone until us
was morally corrupt and and and
um morally insensitive
um
so that's that's that's one thing
so there's nothing there was nothing
exceptional about the British
involvement in slavery in the 70s and
18th centuries
what was exceptional and extraordinary
was that toward the end of the 18th
century
um um partly because of Enlightenment
views mainly because of
Christian views
um
the idea that
owning other human beings as property
began to be questioned on principle
and so in 18 1787 you get the the
creation of the Society of the abolition
of slavery in England
um I think Denmark was the first state
in Europe to abolish the slave trade
within its limited territories
um Britain followed uh three years later
you know seven
1833 the Empire abolished
slavery as an institution within its
territories so so let me just make this
clear because
um at the moment
in recent years we've been encouraged in
Britain
to to uh look again at the horrors of
slavery in which our ancestors were
involved for 150 200 years
as if nothing had changed
uh so so the the the the fact that
Britain was among the first states in
the history of the world
to abolish the slave trade and then to
abolish slavery and it then led the
world in suppressing both of those as I
said from Brazil across Africa to
militia that was extraordinary no other
state had done that before
uh no other states had done that before
certainly not in Africa certainly not in
Asia nor in among the indigenous peoples
of North America that was extraordinary
and and we carried on doing that
for until the end of the empire in the
1960s and in 1820s and 30s the slavery
trade Department in the British foreign
office was the largest unit
um and in the 1830s or the 40s
thereabouts 13 of the total Manpower of
their own Navy was devoted to um
um into in to stopping
uh slave ships leaving West Africa for
the Americas
uh just stopping that quite apart from
stopping slavery elsewhere
um so I do think we need to remember the
the the fact that we couldn't undo what
we've done for 200 years worth of of
enslaving all we could do was stop it
and then try and stop it elsewhere
um so I think we need to remember the
bit of History that's closest to us
Nigel isn't there one reason that
perhaps
it's hard to see things in that way and
that is although I I have a whole
chapter in my book about this as well
and the points you make I make too right
but the one thing that I think we could
all agree was somewhat different about
the British Empire is because it was
technologically the most sophisticated
nation in the world at the time it had
technology that allowed it to transport
people in a way and to places that
previously people would have struggled
to do the idea that you could transport
millions of people across the Atlantic
Ocean really that was that would have
been unavailable to almost anybody and
so even though we know that the
trans-saharan slave trade which took
slaves from sub-Saharan Africa to the to
the Maghrib to the Middle East uh it
lasted longer and had more people and
they were treated far worse by the way
but it doesn't have the same imagery in
our minds as people being stuffed into
the hold of a of a ship in terrible
conditions and be on sale to a
completely foreign land and dump there
and forced to to work in the plantation
isn't that one of the reasons that just
as human beings we we feel a very strong
reaction to to what we're being told
that's a fair point Constantine
um just to be clear the positions didn't
start that the Portuguese were doing
that uh whether they were transporting
slaves to the um uh it was at the Canary
Islands um just off the coast of West
Africa in the 1440s so yes Europeans who
had developed the naval technology to
transport
goods and people across oceans uh I I
suppose that may have been the first
time that had happened and the
conditions and the slave ships were
horrendous
and the wasted the human wastage the the
the percentage of enslaved Africans who
died on Route was was high
although it
for commercial reasons uh um those
trading slaves
um improved conditions such that the
number of people dying the ships
declined silver doesn't excuse it so
that's that's probably true
um
so so the the conditions on the ship on
the slave ships were uh horrendous
um
but I think I
um so notwithstanding that I guess my
point Nigel is sorry but I feel I've
sidetracked you a little bit is it's
almost like you're right everybody had
slaves and in fact in the research that
I did uh somebody argued actually that
slaves were the first good that people
ever traded potentially interesting
um but my point is it's almost like this
is going to sound crass and deliberately
so because I'm trying to make the point
it's like everyone did it but the
British Empire was just better at it and
that's why we're more perhaps ashamed
because we did it on quite a large scale
and very effectively
um yeah so that that might be the case
although I think one shouldn't downplay
the horrors of the
um slave food across Africa and when
when Europeans like David Livingston
witnessed it was just horrible smaller
in scale I grant you nor should we then
play the the horrors of being
um enslaved and carted off to the
customer in North Africa ended up being
a slave galley
um um that wasn't pretty either Laura
eunuch or a sex life yeah but are you
points well taken and there were forms
of slavery in the
Ottoman Empire domestic slavery which
were more Humane so certainly uh more
there were more and less Humane forms of
slavery and the the one in which the
Europeans not just the British engaged
transporting people across the Atlantic
and then the slave plantations was among
the worst yep
I mean what we're talking about is
absolutely horrific and it it leaves its
stain so in many ways do you have a
sympathy with with these people who are
overtly critical of the Empire and can't
really look past that because it is such
a dreadful crime If we're honest
um I guess I don't actually
uh partly because when I look back at
history
I think of it most of it was Dreadful
most of it was Dreadful I mean so I look
back at slavery having looked at
Paul Potts Killing Fields having looked
at the Holocaust having looked at the
well you know the the millions are lost
their lives in German Mouse Great Leap
Forward and Cultural Revolution having
looked at what Stalin did in Russia in
the 1930s
um having considered the Irish famine
having considered so in other words
history is full of
massive inhumanity
um and I I don't mean to diminish the
the awfulness of slavery
uh but you know if you if you want to to
get upset about the past there's an
awful lot you can get it set about
um and I still think I still think and
you know there's nothing you can do
nothing we can do to save those who were
enslaved and treated abominantly by
English or Scottish Sailors in the uh
1700s we can't undo that
um but there was an awful lot of
Injustice about it we can't undo
well the the maltreatment of industrial
workers in mid 19th century Victorian
England we can't undo the injustices
done to
small kids set up chimney Stacks we all
know about that
um
um all we can do is stop it and and try
and rectify the effect now and we did
stop it and we did we did try and
rectify the the the the effects um and
we're still doing that and it was it's a
great financial cost to the British
Empire as well I don't think people also
realize that either
I mean that's controversial so so
um if you follow the the Marxist
um economic historian
um Eric Williams his 1940 book
capitalism of slavery argues that
um the British
made
um the the profits that the British made
from the trade and slavery was a major
um cause of in Business Industrial
Revolution taking off
um but but unless you're a Marxist
uh that's not that's not a um uh it
properly held view now and historians of
um the transatlantic slave trade and
economic historians and they'll disagree
with that
um the to your point about the costs of
anti-slavery
um
David Altus the economic historian I
think has has written that in the period
of roughly
1816 to
the British spent as much
suppressing the slave trading slavery as
they had profited as much in the 50
years before the the abolition
um and as I mentioned in terms of
uh the Royal Navy
um 13 of his Manpower at one's Point
devoted to the West African Squadron I
have read that 17 000 Sailors lost their
lives probably from disease trying to
suppress it
and and that was just the just the
Atlantic
um in fact the empire was involved in
anti-slavery 450 years all over
um now now does that compensate for
150 years of slavery well no but but
um what's done is done uh and so there's
nothing can compensate
uh all you can do is is try and do
better and we have done and Nigel this
is maybe a I don't know is it an unfair
question or not but I feel like because
we have this warped way of looking at
history in in the UK and in the west
more broadly
what do you think that says about us and
and the stage of our civilization that
we're at this excessive introspection
this this kind of very one-dimensional
view of our history is it a signal of
something is it a symptom of some kind
of
disorder I don't know what is it right
well first of all I think it is
dangerous
um
uh and the reason I wrote my book and I
make that clear in the introduction was
political
um and I I don't pretend I don't have a
political interest here I I do try to be
fair
and accurate as far as I can uh but I do
have a political interest here and my
interest is in in the confidence in the
South Conference of the West
uh because I I try to explain why it is
that the the only thing
uh the critics of Empire care about are
white Empires and European Empires
um why is that because I I take it that
the the record of
European Empires and a particularly the
British one is a proxy for the record of
the West and it is I mean for
um in terms of European civilization
from 1815 to 1914 roughly Britain was
the leader
um
and so
um it bothers me
that the wrecker of the West is being
um produced aligned
um because my worry is that it will
reduce the faith of contemporary britons
and younger britons in the west and in
Britain as an important if secondary
pillar of the West so that is
why it matters to me
um
um as to what it says about us I mean I
have puzzled over why I mean in my book
in the
throughout the book I try and
demonstrate how certain historians not
all
have uh taken the evidence and then made
um judgments about the Empire that the
evidence just doesn't support so
the Empire committed genocide in
Tasmania or the Empire committed
um genocide in the Western Plains of
Canada in the 1880s
and I I I I I I lay this out and it
really wants to see the evidences there
in the book and then I say well why why
what propels the Judgment way out in
advance of the evidence what's the
motive for this I mean why go beyond the
evidence
to make a an unsupported critical claim
about British colonialism
um and I say to myself well um
you know it's evidence uh as a committed
Britain and as a committed Western if
they ever if the evidence requires me
obliges me to accept that my people did
awful things in the past
um then I need to accept that but why
would I why would I choose to to believe
that my people did offer things in the
past if the evidence doesn't require me
and I I speculate as to what might be
propelling this but there is
um there's a cut there's clearly on the
part of some
uh critics of Empire
not just a Readiness to accept the truth
about the past but a Glee that they want
to believe the worst well this is why I
bring up the point because the facts are
what the fact I'm we've already talked
about it like all Empires the British
Empire committed many atrocities and did
many bad things and like every society
in history it engaged in slavery
however there is many ways to tell that
story I mean as you point out yourself a
story could be this is a a country that
did terrible things and you leave it
there and you say we're terrible people
who must have turned forever or you
could compare it to elsewhere and also
go make the point that you've made which
is and then we we did what we could and
then we tried to deal with this and we
tried to end it and then actually we had
to force for example countries in the
Middle East to stop trading and slaves a
great cost diplomatically militarily in
human lives and so on but there is a
demand in our society for a particular
story about that and I am concerned as
you are I think that that is not
accidental the the demand for that
particular narrative comes from a desire
to deflate our confidence to to to
demoralize uh people in the UK and the
west and in America about their own
history and I just wonder if you had any
thoughts on you know as a historian on
what happens to societies once they go
down that path
yeah so I quote in the book
um
a passage from a novel by by an Austrian
novel is Robert musil
uh
the novel wasn't completed on his death
in 1942
um it's called
the men without qualities it's called
and it's set in the diet I think before
the first world war
um on the eve of the collapse of the
Australian Empire
and um
I can't remember the the uh passage in
its entirety but what he says is this he
says that
um
confidence in Nations and Empires
collapses in the same way that it
collapses in business concerns
when it's credit is used up
whose credit is used up
um and
um
My worry is that if young britons
believe that 300 years worth of British
engagement was the world from
roughly
um
1650 to 1960 was simply a Litany of of
racism and oppression
then it's bound to shake their
confidence in our institutions that were
built
um and it's also bound to weaken their
resistance to
um illiberal threats from Putin's Russia
or
uh XI jinping's China because the
tendency will say well we know better
than they are and of course which is
what a lot of people are saying yeah the
left has been saying this uh forever and
I think this is partly a refrain of the
of a certain part of the left the hard
left
that actually the West is no better than
the East and that was said during the
Cold War too
um
and I just think it's wrong I just think
it's wrong and um it's something that
why why is it wrong Euro moral
philosopher and an ethicist why is that
wrong Nigel what aren't they just you
know Putin would say you listen to his
speeches says we are an independent
civilization with our own Traditional
Values we do things differently you know
uh Russia is a country geographically
that's it that requires a different sort
of government a different set of values
what what why do you say the West is
better and bear in mind as well that
people on that side of the list would go
well what about Iraq we it was an
illegal Invasion a million people died
and I mean that's you look at Vietnam
there's a lot of Western intervention
that hasn't been productive and in fact
it has been a disaster yeah so why are
we better yeah those are difficult
questions so let's agree that the West
has made um serious mistakes
um
every as I say every nation said or
collection of Nations will have made
serious mistakes
um but it's still true that
um we are
committed
to a
political way of life
in which the power of executive
government is limited by by law
effectively limited by law and that's
one of the features of of
um liberal democratic governments that
it cannot do the kinds of things that
President Putin is doing in Russia
um and although President Putin might
say you know this is the Russian way
there are plenty of Russians speak for
yourself Constantine who disagree and
and even if they plenty of Russians are
critical of the west but even plenty of
people in Russia and indeed in China uh
certainly in Hong Kong
um can see the evils of
um a repressive government that is
subject to no effective legal control
um so if you believe in in the if you
believe that um too much power is a
dangerous thing for any state to have if
you believe in the importance of
um having the power of the state curbed
by law so that individuals can criticize
it or get on with their lives and in the
way they choose if you believe in a
liberal political life then then the
West notwithstanding its mistakes is
something worth believing in
um and there are plenty of people in
Russia and China and Hong Kong today
that would agree with that
that's my view since since you asked
yeah and I think someone sorry for
instance just to finish this point is is
I the reason I ask you is I think we
don't articulate that enough and and so
people forget do you know what I mean
sorry mate well it's funny because
people are saying this they enjoy these
freedoms and the part of my worry about
um contemporary Britain to announce a
little about their history and and I was
growing up I grew up in a time when
um you couldn't get out of school
without having some idea of how we got
in Britain to where we are today in
terms of
uh National and constitutional
development and when I was before I was
10 years old I was laying reams of dates
so I had some idea of the kind of
framework my sense is nowadays young
britons are not taught history that way
at all so they don't have much idea
of where this all came from and so they
just take it for granted and I I do get
frustrated when it seems to me a lot of
my fellow citizens forget just how
extraordinarily fortunate we are
in Britain which now enjoys the greatest
security
wealth Health generally speaking that we
have ever enjoyed and that compared to
most nations in the world
um we're extraordinary uh so I think we
need not to take things for granted the
way we do anyway sorry no I would
completely agree with that Nigel the
question that I want to ask you is
you've been working in Academia I for
the vast majority of your career
have most of these ideas come from
Academia
and what responsibility do you think
Academia should take for this because
there's a lot of people who put the
blame solely at the door of Institutions
like Oxford University Cambridge
University ivy league is that true is
that fair
so do these ideas come from academe
um
my perception is that these radically
critical ideas
[Music]
uh many many of them come from the new
left
they are
a certain kind of marxist idea
which
has these ideas have inhabited certain
regions of Academia for decades but
because of
um
particularly black lives matter activism
they've moved suddenly to the center and
as I as I said because so few even
academics have any idea about Imperial
uh our Imperial past
and because they do know that it's not
it's not cool to be even suspected of
being racist or being pro Empire it's
not even cool to be pro-written frankly
uh the acquiesce so I think
um so yeah some of them have come from
from within universities but
um the activist mood has has given them
a kind of has moved them to the center
stage
um
and it does it does distress and perplex
me that protects me that that
so many of my academic colleagues
acquiesce
um particularly in the notion that for
example that our universities like the
rest of British Society are systemically
racist
when it seems to me there's plenty of
evidence to suppose that isn't the case
and that
um um if there are different outcomes
for a different ethnic groups it's it's
not as simple as that white people do
well and black people don't do well
all right
the evidence is that that ethnic Chinese
do better than most white people and
white poor do even worse than the West
Indian Britain so it's much more
complicated but there's a strange lack
of critical filtering of what comes in
and why is that
um
well I mean you could say it's Covetous
bit of that it's also that um
um in academe as in most institutions
that are subject to bureaucracies all
sorts of nonsense comes down from above
to fight it is exhausting and most of
the time you think God
this is nonsense
but it just it's easier
to follow it and and try and find a way
around it and tick the box and get on
with your life than it is to fight and
particularly when you look around and
think who else is fighting here
and no one is lifting
um
no one is
protesting
and you think oh my God I'm the only
person in the room who thinks this is a
nonsense whereas in fact
nine out of 10 people were thinking just
as you are no one's saying so
uh so it's it's partly um trying to
figure out which battles are worth
fighting I mean charitable here and then
deciding this wasn't isn't worth
fighting the problem is when you do that
again and again and again I mean serious
nonsense gets entrenched and then and
then the job of trying to dislodge it
becomes impossible
um
and I think that's what's what's going
on uh so am I critical of of
um
my academic colleagues
yes I am because I think I think
there comes a point
where you're responsible for allowing
serious nonsense to take root so at the
moment it's decolonizing policies which
are which are based on a series of
assumptions about racism in Britain
today and about what colonial history
really was that are I think false
and uh all is most distressing is that
there's so little critical discussion of
this in University and I think a lot of
University professors are betraying all
they're supposed to be about
um that said uh there are signs of
resistance that have grown up in the
last three years so it's the cause is
not lost here
um in the way that it appears to be lost
in in a lot of ivy league universities
in the states where I'm told I I mean I
don't although I was a graduate student
at one in Chicago in the 1980s I've not
taught there so I don't know what the
atmosphere was like now but it appears
as if it would be much harder to resist
the decolonizing wave and the states
that it is here
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably around near like
the sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape uh not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time do you really
imagine you're gonna get Douglas Murray
near the frozen food aisle if you want
to ask our incredible guest questions
and have access to phenomenal behind the
scenes content then you have to be on
our locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one a baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
because the problem is Nigel like you
just said that if you don't challenge
these ideas at the root then they will
work their way in and they will fester
and they will take hold to the point
where you write a book
that is a perfectly legitimate analysis
of the British Empire and it gets
canceled why was that how did that
happen
yeah well I mean that wasn't the fault
of academic colleagues
almost anything else on them yeah yeah
yeah yeah not that one uh I mean there
was a an earlier as we talked about this
last time but the uh the attempt to
cancel my ethics nearby project in
2017-18
um that was done by academic colleagues
uh who now
um who now
um
adamantly protested that this wasn't a
repressive thing at all
but we'll we'll go back into that on the
book so what happened with the book was
um I mean that's what we're saying
earlier
if only my critics
knew um what good service they performed
for me because uh actually
um because of that
um the attempt to suppress my ethics
Empire project in December 2017 in
um the spring of 2018 I signed a
contract write a book on colonialism
because the publisher came to me and
said Harvard writing an intelligent
Person's Guide to colonialism
uh which I agreed to do so I got a
contract out of it
um and then what happened was
um I had to produce the manuscript
uh by New Year's but by the close of
December 2020.
and so at 3 P.M
on New Year's Eve on 2020 I dispatched
the manuscript with the whole nine hours
to spare
and then early 21 my uh commissioning
editor
wrote back he read the manuscript he
said he used the word
um
what was the word
speechless was the word he used
um with admiration for the
comprehensiveness and the rigor with
which I had written and he said this is
an important book he said it twice and
he predicted sales of between 15 and 20
000 copies which may not seem big to you
but that's a lot yeah particularly for
academic leaning book well I I can tell
you I I've been writing books since
1986 and I don't think I've in total I
don't think I've sold more than about 6
000 copies so that was big venues for me
so uh that's where we were in January 21
uh and he put the manuscripts into the
copy editing process of Bloom's
republishing this is the publisher
they even designed a cover and then in
March 21 I got an email from the top of
Bloomsbury and I'm seeing that uh
they were going to postpone publication
indefinitely because
um and I quote public feeling is
unfavorable
and I was I was shocked I feared this
would happen because it's happened in
the states
um I was shocked um
being a man of a certain age my emotions
are
about two weeks behind behind me so I I
wasn't quite sure what I felt but my
wife
uh reports that I was devastated and I
do remember lying down my bed staring at
the ceiling feeling sorry for myself so
I was very sorry at the prospect that
what I thought was an important
contribution to public discourse would
never get published
but more depressed and thought that
Britain had come to a place where
a publisher a major publisher would
decline to publish an important book
that's selling up to 20 000 copies would
make them a profit why
because public feelings unfavorable
um and I was I was told uh and I I
inquired and what does this mean that I
was told in fact Bloomsbury wanted me to
walk away from the contract
um so I decided not to do that and I
engaged them in um innocent
correspondence and I said innocently
so you say that public feelings are
favorable
there's lots of public feeling which one
are you referring to
and I said so conditions are not
favorable
well when will conditions become
and I was hoping they might actually be
honest and tell me in print but the
lawyers probably advise them not to so
um I got two responses which revealed
nothing at all
uh and then in early April
notwithstanding the fact they couldn't
explain which public feeling
was upsetting them in early April I got
an email saying we're sure you were
impatient to have this book published so
we're going to return your contract to
you
um and even then I wasn't willing to to
bite
so I um
I I paid 700 quid to a lawyer in the
hope that she might tell me that my I
could hold Bloomsbury to my contract
and uh several hundred pounds poorer I
discovered I couldn't
so then I then this is about three weeks
after I got the email from women's where
I wrote and said
okay uh since you give me no choice
I will receive the contract back
um but I want you to know what I think
of you and what I said was I'm just
appalled I mean I I understand
Publishers need to make money
but but don't publishers also have a
kind of civic duty to keep our liberal
space liberal and to to inject important
views into the liberal public space just
in case prevailing orthodoxies are
mistaken
and I I mean maybe that's wrong but I
just it seem to me that if every
publisher main boomsbury the wavelengths
we did we in Britain and our Public
Country would be severely severely
impoverished
um so that's what happened then and then
um happily uh another publisher at
William Collins
um took up what
blooms were thrown away and I got a
contract in August 21 uh with William
Collins to publish and they brought it
out
uh early uh in February
and just before it was published I
decided to share the email
correspondence I had with rooms with a
journalist who published at the Times
and got a response from doomsbury and
their line is that uh Professor bigger
opted to leave his contract
I I
given what I've told you
um I'll leave you to draw your own
conclusions from that because there were
and I I was listening to another
interview you did by way of research and
you intimated that it was some of the
younger employees at Bloomsbury who may
have instigated this whole thing early
on I was told that was the problem
that the Senior Management had been
lobbied by younger
members of staff
who objected to producing Biggers
manuscript
now
um I only have that one witness it was a
senior witness from inside the
institution
deny that
but the only other explanation of given
namely that I walked away from it is
disingenuous I did walk away who in the
end because they gave me no choice
and I observed that the phenomenon of
junior staff
somehow managing to to cow Senior
Management into vetoing Publications
um as has been a widespread when we've
heard reports of the newspaper so until
booms we come up with a better
explanation uh that's the most plausible
one I have and what does that say about
our society
let's remove that particular example but
this has happened time and time again we
saw it happen with Jordan Peterson's
book where they weren't successful
because the Publishers are not saying no
that Jordan's books will sell incredibly
well but what does it say when
authors who aren't at the level of
Jordan in terms of sales get their books
canceled because Junior employees who
probably haven't even read the
manuscript decide that it's unacceptable
what does that mean for us as a society
uh
uh it's it's it's terrifying really um
I'll just
to me it's really odd uh I wanna I wanna
know where did the grown-ups go and
67 so I'm accustomed to growing up
saying no to non-grown-ups right
um we had it we had a conference
that I ran in Oxford in 2019 on academic
freedom under threat what's to be done
did you come to that yeah okay yeah if
that's when we met
and um I remember one of the one of the
kind of um takeaways from that
was the observation one of the problems
is that we we now live in a period when
our institutions are are governed by
um a generation of parents who
who lost in the sense of having
authority over their kids now I'm not a
parent
uh I I deeply I I I have no end of
respect for those who choose to become
parents because it seems to be bloody
hard work
yeah
just tell me if I'm wrong
um but I I take it that sometimes one
has to say no to one's kid well not to
say no Toons kids four months kids sake
um but I get the impression that a lot
of
parents middle class parents University
educated parents
I have difficulty doing that why do I
say that
um
you've got eyes and ears and if you look
around the society you can see it
everywhere well for example I've heard
um I was taught twice I I've spoken to
teachers
in private schools
and ask them in terms of I mean it tips
to me that it's really important for
kids to learn how to use social media
well how to discriminate
uh and how you know not to spend the
whole time plugged into it and I I ask
teachers what they do
to to help kids manage social media and
uh the technology well
and they say well we can do something
but we think Parents Ought to do
something
but the problem we're facing is that
parents come to us and say
would you please tell little Johnny to
stop using his iPhone all the time
because I don't dare to I don't dare to
says the parent and this this is in
this is the context of a high fee paying
schools so this is presumably a parent
who is a university education uh is is
very wealthy very successful doesn't
dare say no to Johnny now you know
I don't know how widespread it is but if
that's that's the case then we have a
generation of
senior Publishers who just don't dare
say no uh is that it
or is it also a a sense that
there's a commercial reason to be on the
right side of history I mean I don't
well not in your case I mean they
predicted the book will sell and by the
way this is the other thing I mean
controversy does generate sales yeah so
with your book which was likely to have
an element of controversy to it I don't
imagine the financial might have had
anything to do with it on the contrary I
think you're right that the you know
these are people who are afraid of
telling their junior employees no okay
we've heard your opinion and it's it's
welcome as a contribution but we're not
going ahead with it uh I think that's
probably it Nigel thankfully you did
manage to get the book published so
there are shoots of some sort of
resistance building what we've got about
five minutes left what was what has the
response been like uh and yeah the
reviews and so on how how have you found
that yeah uh
so the responses have been mixed
predictably uh so they've been throwing
reviews in the guardian Nigel yeah yeah
that was probably a little too much to
hope for from
um so so very good reviews in Sunday
Times uh Trevor Phillips
um uh
um
maybe he he used the phrase which I I
love to quote he said this book quote
carries the intellectual force of an
anti uh a javelin anti-tank missile I
like that so A number of good reviews
but last weekend for example there was a
slew of about four
hostile reviews uh which
eventually I I stealed myself to read
um
and I think I although I was feeling
kind of a bit better about them I think
I what I need to accept is the fact that
the line I'm pushing
that actually Empire is not necessarily
Wicked and the British Empire actually
uh contained a lot of admirable things
is so unfashionable
um
the last time when this kind of like
would have been 50 years ago
and I'm an ethicist I'm the only person
ethicist who's ever tried to do it
um
the current generation of historians is
is going direct to that with instinctive
hostility besides
um
um if they didn't I mean the cost of
approving of bigger in public
career-wise would be high so they're not
going to do that for that reason so I
just have to have to accept there will
be hostile reviews certainly in the
guardian a new Statesman and I swear but
having looked at at the Hostile
responses I observe first of all so so a
number of focus
um particularly
fellow called Ellen lestert
um Sussex university has been very busy
on Twitter
identifying particular historical points
I've got wrong
and places where I miss the evidence or
whatever so let me be thank you and say
you know the the canvas of British
imperial history alone is vast that is
300 years 1650 roughly to 1960 and runs
from Newfoundland to to New Zealand it's
fast
so
um had I made mistakes without a doubt I
made mistakes uh and and and when I when
I come across them I will in due course
uh correct myself but I observe that
um
the attention of some of my critics has
been a very kind of micro level and no
one has really taken on in fact no one
has really paid attention to the larger
argument
so so far my larger argument stands uh
the kind of argument I've just
articulated to you earlier
and I also noticed not for the first
time that in order to take me down some
of my critics have to
allegedly I said things I never said so
one of them says the biggest things
there's a vast array of historians out
there who
um who hold these extreme opinions
and I'm sorry to disappoint John Wilson
of King's College London but I didn't
write the book for him I wrote the book
I didn't write the book for historians I
wrote it wrote it for the primarily for
the for the literate British public
to give them some idea that the the uh
the radically
anti-colonialist decolonizing story that
the Empire with all the Litany of racism
repression is just not true it's not
true to the facts that's the audience I
care about
and
um nor did I claim I never claimed it
was a vast array of historians there are
certainly some uh um and although Wilson
discount the likes of Caroline Elkins
um the truth is that Elkins has far more
impact than than Wilson does so I was
interested in those historians who have
public impact
um and then then another reviewer said
that I end up saying that the British
Empire was essentially humanitarian I
don't say that at draw so so they keep
having to erect straw man to hit me and
that kind of reassures me because you
only are extra man if you can't hit the
real Target
so I I'm you know I'm still monitoring
the the critics
um but uh so far uh that nothing
devastating has been produced and I just
observe uh the fact that uh the sales of
the book have been extraordinarily High
I didn't expect anything like the
um um response that's been in the Sunday
Times best so there's two weeks running
which is is really encouraging because
what it means is there is a a large
public appetite in this country and I
hope when it's published in the US and
in May there are two a large public
appetite for something that tries to be
reasonable and moderate and careful and
even-handed no I do yeah so yeah yeah I
finished
I was going to say thank you so much it
was a genuine it's always a joy to talk
to you and even more so in this
interview uh our interviews always end
with the same question which is what's
one thing we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be
um I would say
we need to sit back and and think more
carefully about our use of words
so for example let's have an adult
conversation about what racism is what
we mean by racism
or when we talk about being harmed
by someone else's opinion or where we
talk about someone else's opinion doing
us violence can we talk about what we
mean by violence and harm
um because a lot of things are commonly
said that if you sit back
and you think no not really I mean you
know I can say things that you find
offensive or upsetting you can say
things that I find upsetting are you
harming me no are you doing me violence
no you're not so I just think we need to
have the courage to think about our
language more carefully
that's my that's mine that's the
oversight I think yeah you still believe
words have meaning very old-fashioned
but
I'm happy now Nigel uh colonialism a
moral Reckoning I hope you get a few
more sales off the back of this
interview it's been a great pleasure
having you back on the show wish you all
the very best and uh thank you for being
here and thank you guys for watching and
listening we will be back with another
brilliant episode like this one or raw
show all of them go out at 7km UK time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it is always
available as a podcast head on over to
locals where we're going to ask your
questions to Nigel that you and you only
are going to hear the answers too take
care and see you soon
I would like to know if the professor
sees any Improvement in Academia since
the last time you were on the show
[Music]